based on the laws of energy conservation
energy in equals energy out if we
exercise more increasing our energy out
whilst our energy in stays the same
in theory you might think that would
lead to weight loss but is this really
the case
well hello and welcome to the cheeky
science show where in this video we're
going to look at this recent cell paper
that shows that actually energy
compensation seems to be occurring
so what does this mean for weight loss
and exercise let us explore so the first
concept we need to understand is what is
it that uses up energy in our bodies and
that's best described as our total
energy expenditure and thus itself can
be split up into two further categories
including activity energy expenditure
aee
and basal energy expenditure bee so for
us activity energy expenditure accounts
for our physical activity the energy
used to move our muscles etc
whilst our basal energy expenditure
includes all of the other processes like
immune system function brain function
liver function and well the function of
different organs
that enable our bodies to function
and this last section is referred to as
a thermic effect of food which
we won't talk about in this video
because it's quite hard to actually
calculate so it isn't really discussed
in the study so for now we just need to
understand that total energy expenditure
includes b-flow activity and our basal
energy expenditure so how does our total
energy expenditure change when we
increase our physical activity well
before the study there were three main
competing theories for how energy
expenditure might vary with increased
activity
the first one is known as the additive
model so quite simply if you increase
your activity levels you would also
increase your total energy expenditure
by the same amount and so in both these
situations the basal energy expenditure
is assumed to be the same such that if
you look at these two graphs you can see
that there's no correlation between the
basal and activity energy expenditure
which makes sense because in this model
the activity is soon to be independent
and therefore uncorrelated
and so if there was variation in the
basal energy expenditure that would
result in variation in the total energy
expenditure
the second model is the performance
model and here you can see that if you
increase your activity levels that
increases total energy expenditure
similarly to the additive model but this
time there's also an increase in the
basal energy expenditure
so suggesting that there's greater need
for metabolic machinery to support
higher activity energy expenditure and
therefore predicting that the total
calories burnt due to activity will be
higher than just the calories used
during the activity because of
additional energy spent on subsequent
physical recovery and maintenance of a
more expensive metabolic machinery to
support this behavior
and then the last model is the
compensation model so here if you
increase activity energy expenditure you
see that there's a decline in the basal
energy expenditure such that the total
energy expenditure actually stays the
same so you compensate for the increased
activity by reducing the basal energy
expenditure so which strategy is it well
that's exactly what they try to explore
in this study as having this information
will be really important for developing
management strategies for weight control
and so the way that they did this is
they exploited this huge data set of
energy expenditure calculations that i
actually discussed all about in a
previous video where they used this
doubly labeled water technique to get
good predictions of basal energy
expenditure and total energy expenditure
and so they just had to be able to use
this information to work out which model
best fits the data
so this is the relationships that they
could see from their data sets and so
well what model does it actually fit
under as it doesn't seem to fit any of
the model predictions i just spent all
that time talking to you about well
let's take a closer look at what these
graphs are actually showing
so let's start with the graph on the
right because it's probably easier to
understand so what we can see here is
actually a negative relationship whereby
at higher activity energy expenditures
there's a lower basal energy expenditure
and so this actually fits in line with
the model of energy compensation the
idea that with increased activity
there's a reduction in basal energy
expenditure to compensate to allocate
that energy budget to recover from this
increased physical activity but if we
then look at the graph on the left we
see that there's still a linear
relationship between basal energy
expenditure and total energy expenditure
which means it doesn't 100
fit the energy compensation model and so
that linear relationship is what we saw
in the additive model and well it's also
seen in the performance model but the
key difference to notice is that it's
more about the strength of this
correlation between bee and tee that's
actually important because in the data
sets they see that the correlation has a
value of 0.723 so the slope is weaker
than the relationship seen in the
additive model and so if the correlation
equals 1 it assumes that there's
no link between active and basal
components of energy expenditure but the
fact that it's less than one suggests
that there's a considerable degree of
compensation occurring
between the active and basal components
and so we know that from looking at the
graph from the right
but the fact is it's not a hundred
percent compensation the compensation is
around 27.7
and so i tried to draw out what this
model predicts based on those stacks
that we saw earlier and another way of
thinking about it is that if you do a
workout and it says you burnt 300
calories so you decide to eat 300
calories of foods it is likely that you
would have a net energy intake due to
the energy compensation because your
basal energy expenditure has declined to
compensate
if that makes sense
now another interesting thing that they
noticed in this data set is that they
looked at how this energy compensation
varied depending on body fatness and
what was found beside those with a lower
body mass index so the lower 10
percentile
showed a 28
energy compensation whilst those in the
upper 10 percentile
had a 49
compensation so basically body fatness
was correlating with greater energy
compensation and so
in the case of someone with a bmi of 35
only about half of the calories spent on
activity translate to a total daily
energy expenditure and so this is one of
the important findings from the study
because it has the downside that those
with obesity who are trying to increase
activity to lose weight
may find it more challenging due to the
fact that they seem to have increased
energy compensation and so the obvious
question for this is why does this
happen and what are the consequences of
having a reduced bee and why does energy
compensation increase of body fatness is
it due to genetics or does it develop as
body fatness increases
well at the moment these questions can't
be answered from this dataset and the
findings that have been shown obviously
it would be nice to see them further
validated
with different cohorts
and taken with the same patients at
multiple time points but it certainly
raises some interesting questions
john speakman one of the authors on this
paper has a very nice tweet tutorial is
that what we call them uh discussing the
key highlights from this paper as well
that if you're interested in finding out
some more then i recommend you take a
read through it but anyway i hope you've
learned something in this video and
understand a bit more about energy in
and energy out and how this might
implicate future personalized treatment
options for managing weight and exercise
so with that i'd like to thank my
patreon supporters and thank you for
listening